مرحله اخرى لاداره ازمه الشمال السوري بين
موسكو وانقره سير الدوريات المشتركه لقوات
البلدين في قرن خاضعه للسيطره ما تعرف
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه شمالي الحسكه
لها دخان القصف التركي وتصعد التهديد
بعمليه عسكريه بريه مؤجله هل باستئناف
الدوريات تكون وجهه نظر الرئيسين اردوان
تقاربت بشان هذا الملف المتشابك تحدث
الراسان هاتفيه لاحد الماضي قبل وبعد
الاتصال لم تتوقف اللجان المشتركه بين
البلدين التابعه للخارجيه والدفاع في
التواصل من اجل خفض التوتر على الحدود
التركيه السوريه من تركمانستان رسائل
الرئيس اردوغان للدعيمين لم تعرفوا بقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه كانت محضره ومهدده في
ان واحد دعى جميع على اطراف وفي كلماتها
واشنطن الى قطع الدعم عما سماها المنظمات
الارهابيه مؤكدا ان تركيا ستقوم بما يقع
على عاتقها في حال استمرار هذا الدعم كان
البنتاجون اعلن قبل ايام قليل استئناف
الدوريات المشتركه بين الولايات المتحده
وما تعرف بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه بعد
تعليقها بسبب الضربات الجويه التركيه في
العشرين من نوفمبر الماضي اطلقت انقر
سلسله ضربات جويه استهدفت مواقع لحزب
العمال الكردستاني في العراق وايضا
الفصائل الكرديه في سوريا
اعتبرته الرد المناسبه على تفجير شارع
الاستقلال في اسطنبول ضربات الجويه والقصف
المدعي استمر رغم رفض موسكو حليفه النظام
دمشق وورشه الداعمه لبعض الفصائل الكرديه
في سوريا عمليات العسكريه ممثله كانت
الدبلوماسيه قد اوقفتها سابقا في 2019
سمحت اتفاق بين موسكو وانق باخماد النيران
عمليه تركيه ونص على انشائي منطقه امنه
بعمق 30 كلم لحمايه تركيا من هجمات قد
تاتي من الاراضي السوريه
واقر اتفاق اخر في السنه نفسها برعايه
واشنطن ومسكو على انسحاب القوات الكرديه
الى مسافه 30 كم من الحدود التركيه بدا ان
تركيا تتهم روسيا والولايات المتحده بعدم
احترام الاتفاقيات وتقول انهما فشيله في
ابعاد واحده حمايه الشعب عن حدودها وتلويح
اردوغان بعمليه بريه ورقه ضغط صالح
للاستخدام في اكثر من ملفا مع دمشق ومسكو
مباشر الشمال السوري تحت رحمه حسابات
المعقده داخليا واقلاميا وتوليا